y
[Música]
segunda noche de protestas contra los
abusos policiales en bogotá tras la
muerte del abogado javier ordóñez a
manos de dos policías que usaron varias
veces una pistola taser en la capital y
otras ciudades de colombia se
registraron enfrentamientos entre los
manifestantes y los agentes ya se
cuentan al menos 10 víctimas fatales y
más de 400 heridos entre civiles y
policías
en parís la capital francesa se adelanta
hoy el consejo de defensa sanitario de
francia donde el gobierno de manuel
macro plantea endurecer las políticas
contra el hobby 19 y establecer una
gestión a largo plazo de la política
social del país tenemos información
desde la ciudad
y al menos 500.000 personas han sido
evacuadas en el estado de oregón eeuu
ante los voraces incendios que azotan la
costa este del país los bomberos siguen
luchando contra al menos 100 focos que
se extienden desde el norte del estado
de washington hasta santiago en el sur
de california
actualizamos la información de américa
latina y del mundo aquí en 324 mi nombre
es liliana valencia iniciamos en
colombia donde se vivió una segunda
noche de protestas contra la brutalidad
policial tras la muerte del abogado
javier ordóñez que murió la madrugada de
este miércoles a manos de la policía
anoche se registraron desmanes incendios
y enfrentamientos entre los
manifestantes y la policía que dejan al
menos 10 personas muertas y más de 400
heridos de los cuales al menos 60 estar
heridos por impactos de bala
varias estaciones de policía fueron
incendiadas y durante las jornadas se
registraron al menos 15 concentraciones
en diferentes puntos de bogotá la
capital la mayoría de ellas iniciaron de
manera pacífica pero terminaron en
enfrentamientos con la policía
entretanto las autoridades han condenado
el vandalismo y el uso de la violencia
contra uniformados que dejan al menos
194 policías lesionados según el
ministerio de defensa de colombia
de parte contable manifestó
las personas
de alguna manera
se mueve es la situación del país está
ahora mismo muy mal sherrill o se hace
gobiernan
[Aplausos]
[Música]
nuestro periodista luís muñoz estuvo
anoche en uno de los puntos de
concentración y en bogotá desde donde
nos envió el siguiente reporte
otra noche de protestas en bogotá esto
es el park güell y un céntrico parque de
bogotá de clase media donde también
viven extranjeros existen teatros
restaurantes y en el que ha vuelto a
incendiarse la estación de policía todo
comenzado cuando había una protesta
donde había una velatón por la memoria
de los diez fallecidos en la noche
anterior en las protestas en
conmemoración por la muerte a manos de
la policía de javier ordóñez el abogado
que recibió más de 10 descargas
eléctricas que le acabaron costando la
vida en el bar way todo iba con cierta
normalidad había gritos de asesinos
había cierta tensión también derechos
humanos mediando entre policía y
manifestantes y finalmente la policía
decidió cargar con bombas aturdidoras
perseguir a los manifestantes y en ese
momento quedaron unos manifestantes
rezagados que aprovecharon para
incendiar la estación de policía
cambiamos de información porque la puja
entre la policía de buenos aires y el
gobierno por la mejora de sus
condiciones laborales acabó con una
pequeña victoria para los uniformados
después de varios días de protestas
lograron que el ejecutivo le reconociera
un tímido aumento de salario y
regresaron a sus labores
pero quedan sinsabores en el aire andrea
rincón nos cuenta más
la policía le ganó el primer round al
gobierno argentino en una batalla de
largo aliento por exigir mejores
condiciones laborales los uniformados de
la provincia de buenos aires anunciaron
el cese de las protestas que por primera
vez llegaron hasta la residencia del
presidente argentino luego de que el
gobernador anunciara que aumentaría el
salario de más de 39 mil efectivos de la
capital argentina donde habitan unas 17
millones de personas va a ver una
equiparación inmediata de 39 mil 521
oficiales de policía
que pasarán a percibir un salario de
bolsillo de 44 mil pesos esto equivale
más o menos a 557 dólares anteriormente
ganaban unos 502 dólares pero este
aumento del 11 por ciento les parece
insuficiente no sólo porque la semana
pasada el presidente alberto fernández
aprobó una inversión de 460 millones de
dólares para reforzar la seguridad de la
provincia de buenos aires donde los
delitos aumentaron en un 30% sino porque
su trabajo se multiplicó por la pandemia
que demandó mayor pie de fuerza debido a
las restricciones agradecemos que no
puedan dar una mesa de diálogo pero no
podemos llegar a un acuerdo porque
nuestro primer mundo fundamental que
pedimos no fue escuchado insistir a los
nombrados que fuentes no queremos que
escriban a nuestro compañero no nos
garantiza que saliendo no vamos a
terminar sumariados
los policías esperan que el gobierno
cumpla y que sus condiciones empiecen a
mejorar pero la desconfianza estatal
crece en un país que lleva más de dos
años en recesión económica y ahora
batalla por superar la pandemia
el 11 de marzo de este año la
organización mundial de la salud declaró
oficialmente que el coronavirus había
llegado a niveles de pandemia en estos
seis meses más de 28 millones 200 mil
personas han resultado contagiadas la
cifra de víctimas fatales supera las
novecientas 10.000 entretanto los
recuperados son más de 19 millones a
nivel mundial la humanidad espera por la
aprobación de una vacuna en medio de una
lenta reapertura acompañada de nuevos
casos en los cinco continentes
vamos ahora a parís donde hoy tiene
lugar el consejo de defensa sanitario de
francia donde se plantea ajustar la
política y las estrategias para la
contención del coi 19 y una gestión a
largo plazo de la política social del
país allí se encuentra nuestra
periodista natalia ruiz con los detalles
de esta información natalia buenos días
tardes ya para usted cuéntenos
exactamente qué se está discutiendo en
este consejo sanitario de seguridad
sí muy buenos días bueno pues este
consejo está ciento por ciento enfocado
precisamente en esta pandemia de
coronavirus en donde los casos siguen
repuntando aquí en francia en las
últimas 24 horas se llegó a 10.000 casos
en el país algo que no se había
reportado desde el comienzo de esta
crisis sanitaria en la mesa de de marzo
el presidente manuel marco dijo en la
noche de este jueves que lo que quiere
es dar más visibilidad a cómo va a ser
la vida en las próximas semanas y que
por eso se están reuniendo el día de hoy
además de esto el consejo científico que
es el que viene asesorando el gobierno
nacional en cuanto a todos estos temas
de la corona virus ha dicho que el
gobierno va a tener que tomar decisiones
difíciles esas decisiones que además van
a tener una repercusión tan sólo en unos
10 a 15 días así que el gobierno lo que
quiere evitar a todo precio es un nuevo
confinamiento general pero si es posible
que ahora digamos le pasen las
responsabilidades más a los territorios
a las autoridades locales para que sean
ellas las que determinen si va a haber
por ejemplo confinamientos a nivel local
cambiar por ejemplo
periodo de apertura de lugares que
atiendan a público y también haya quizás
restricciones al desplazamiento de las
personas sobre todo en las zonas que
están en digamos alerta roja por el gran
número de casos italia pero cuéntenos
además cuáles serían las medidas
principales que deberían o podrían
anunciarse durante esta jornada por
parte del gobierno
así después se espera que sus anuncios
sean ya caída esta tarde será hoy y el
ministro de salud quien haga estos
anuncios ante los franceses hay dos
decisiones principales por una parte
recortar el tiempo de la cuarentena que
pasaría de 14 días a 7 días esto porque
ya digamos que a partir del octavo día
una persona no es contagiosa en todo
caso eso fue lo que dijo el consejo
científico y eso también permitiría que
la gente cumpliera más con esta medida
de aislamiento algo que no está
sucediendo porque en francia no se está
rompiendo la cadena de contagio y por
otra parte la idea es también hacer unos
tests que sean mucho más prioritarios
para las personas que tienen síntomas y
también para las personas que han estado
en contacto con alguien que haya dado
positivo estos textos diferentes de los
test moleculares del psr que ustedes
conocen y que es la prueba de antigénico
una prueba que es mucho más rápida
porque el resultado se obtiene en tan
solo 15 a 20 minutos y permite de esta
manera pues hacer unos tests mucho más
importantes a nivel nacional así que
éstas serían digamos las dos medidas más
importantes que se espera se anuncia en
el día de hoy
por ahora se sabe que estos test anti
higiénicos deberían ponerse en marcha en
todo caso aquí en isla de francia que es
el departamento que alberga a parís pero
es también posible que sea una medida
para el resto del país
natalia ruiz esa periodista en parís con
la información gracias natal y
continuamos con más noticias vamos ahora
a eeuu porque los incendios que azotan
la costa oeste del país siguen
acelerando california y oregón son los
estados más afectados y al menos 500.000
personas han sido evacuadas después de
que las llamas ya habían consumido
centenares de viviendas los bomberos
siguen luchando contra al menos 100
focos que se extienden desde el norte
del estado de washington hasta san diego
en el sur de california justamente en el
estado de washington miles de familias
han resultado afectadas por las llamas
que este año han consumido el doble de
hectáreas en comparación con el año
pasado sólo en oregón 364 mil han
resultado incinerada durante los últimos
tres días según indican las autoridades
locales
si nos acercamos aproximadamente 364 mil
hectáreas quemadas en todo el estado
para poner ese número en perspectiva en
los últimos 10 años vemos un promedio de
202 mil 342 hectáreas quemadas en todo
un año en el fire within a lydia bosch
hemos visto casi el doble en los últimos
tres días nunca habíamos visto esa
cantidad de fuego fuera de control en
todo nuestro estado si vamos con más
noticias destacadas de la mañana aquí en
france 24
el secretario de estado de eeuu mike
pompeo expresó su apoyo a las anunciadas
conversaciones de paz entre el gobierno
afgano y los insurgentes talibanes-
consideradas históricas con peor a
presencia en doha la capital de qatar
donde tendrá lugar la apertura de los
diálogos entre tanto el presidente trova
anunció la retirada de cuatro mil
militares americanos de afganistán y
2000 en irak
japón y reino unido- cerraron el primer
acuerdo comercial después de la salida
del reino unido- de la unión europea el
primer ministro británico boris johnson
calificó el tratado como un momento
histórico al tiempo que se agudizan las
tensiones con la unión europea ante la
posibilidad de que el acuerdo alcanzado
no entre en vigor
y hoy se cumplen 19 años del atentado
contra las torres gemelas y el pentágono
en eeuu los hechos dejaron un total de 2
mil 977 víctimas fatales en el pentágono
se hizo la bandera del país y se esperan
conmemoraciones durante esta jornada en
este momento histórico y también en
honor de las víctimas en nueva york'
con el foco puesto solo en los contagios
de ccoo y 19 los pacientes venezolanos
con otras patologías han quedado
relegados es el caso de las personas con
parkinson o trasplantadas debido a la
atención puesta en la pandemia y a las
sanciones de eeuu muchos no están
recibiendo sus medicamentos porque no
ingresaron con regularidad al país
durante los últimos meses en milla
fernández nos cuenta más desde caracas
el riñón que le transplantaron a jessica
solórzano hace menos de dos años corre
peligro
la cuarentena por kobe 19 ha afectado
seriamente el despacho de medicamentos
de alto costo por parte del gobierno y
los pacientes no los están obteniendo a
tiempo esta situación que empezó con la
crisis económica de venezuela se ha
venido agravando con las sanciones de
eeuu al país está básicamente una
sentencia de muerte para nosotros porque
no tenemos cómo comprar los medicamentos
y el seguro social no nos da es una
desesperación un miedo constante de que
el día de cualquier día puedes rechazar
el órgano porque no tienes los
medicamentos
estefanía lugo de 9 años tras un
trasplante de hígado hecho con la
donación de 70 mil dólares tiene un poco
más de suerte porque una fundación está
dando los medicamentos más importantes
aún con esta ayuda es difícil para su
madre costear el resto del tratamiento
por la situación económica
está costoso la alimentación es parte
del tratamiento de ella porque su
alimentación debe ser balanceada muy
sana muy rigurosa en ese sentido y bueno
con los ingresos que percibimos tenemos
que hacer maraña las decenas de personas
que acuden a diario las farmacias del
gobierno y se van con las manos vacías
ya comienzan a tener consecuencias
alexander hernández pacientes con
parkinson dijo que recibe reportes
mensuales de que están muriendo de 5 a 6
personas con esta condición médica por
no poder tomar sus medicinas
yo pongo a siete partidos que tengo diez
sale con la condición que interrumpir
tratamiento sea un pago muscular tan
fuerte que te pueda un parent estirar un
paro respiratorio y eso lo que es la
manera el paciente está sufriendo hoy en
día el mayor temor que tienen los
pacientes crónicos en venezuela que
visitan farmacias como éstas es que no
pueden seguir sorteando las dificultades
y que tengan que pagar esos tratamientos
lo cual causaría un daño irreparable en
su salud y los llevaría incluso hasta la
muerte
herminia fernández france24 caracas
así finalizamos entradas 24 pero los
invitamos a visitar nuestra página web
france24 puntocom para ampliar la
información en de américa latina y el
mundo en cuatro idiomas nos vemos más
adelante con más información quédense
extras 24
[Música]